mehr als 70 expertinnen und experten aus wirtschaft und politik haben sich auch in diesem jahr zum world economic
forum in davos getroffen und über nichts geringeres beraten als über unsere zukunft über die wirklich großen
globalen fragen dieser welt was sind die größten gefahren wie wird sich unser leben in den nächsten jahren ändern
Werden internet gegangen wie google und so weiter die macht übernehmen und inwieweit sind regierungen weltweit eine gefahr für unsere jetzige
zivilisation ihr habt euch dieses spannende thema whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt die drei wichtigsten fragen dazu beantwortet herzlich willkommen bei klicks um
science-fiction
ja und wir täglich an die neuesten infos auf whatsapp kommt und bei klick zum mitmachen können dass der vater am ende des videos
auf der 3 werden wir heimlich von internet giganten regiert als einer von vielen warnte beispielsweise der ungarische mehr der george soros vor
Allmächtigen internetgiganten diese seien schon seit längerer zeit dabei immer mächtiger zu werden und könnten sich im worst case auch mit
autoritären regime verbünden vielleicht sagen einige von euch die science fiction
storys von george orwell oder aldous huxley etwas auch in ihren romanen geht es um überwachung
szenarien die der realen welt lockt source vielleicht allerdings schon bald in nichts mehr nachstehen
als längst überfällig bezeichnete der investor mehr regeln für die konzerne
beispielsweise durch die
Eu-wettbewerbskommission kleiner fun fact am rande während der rede von source die immer größer werdende macht von facebook google und so weiter
anmahnte waren die zuschauer des world economic forums fleißig dabei seine äußerung genau in diesen sozialen netzwerken zu teilen
aber die antwort lautet source also ja sie sind ziemlich mächtig und zwar bald schon
übermächtig und wir müssen etwas dagegen tun ja war ein krasses
statement auf der zwei werden einzelne herrscher kriege
provozierend einige experten experten das wort er konnte vor uns sehen auf verschiedene regierungen weltweit als
entscheidender knackpunkt für unsere zukunft vor allem der amerikanische präsident
donald trump wird von vielen als echte gefahr gesehen auch dazu hat sich der ungarische investor george soros
geäußert in den vereinigten staaten würde präsident kommt gerne einen mafia staat errichten aber er schafft es nicht die verfassung andere
institutionen und die lebendige ziel gesellschaft stehen dem entgegen
ähnlich wie kim jong un in nordkorea habe er keine scheu atomwaffen einzusetzen
Das, sei ein großes risiko für die gesamte menschheit als große gefahr wurde auch der wachsende rechtspopulismus in europa identifiziert
Laut der deutschen bundeskanzlerin angela merkel gift das von ungelösten problemen angetrieben werden und tatsächlich
muss der wachsende rechtspopulismus schleunigst unter kontrolle gebracht werden mehr der songs geht noch weiter und bezeichnet das
parteiensystem in deutschland als weitestgehend
unfähig seine erklärung dazu durch das auftauchen der afg sei die csu weiter nach rechts gerutscht zwischen den unionsparteien sei und
unüberbrückbarer graben entstanden also auch hier werden große gefahren durch autokratische
regime und die entwicklung der parteienlandschaft gesehen auf der eins sorgen
digitalisierung und künstliche intelligenz für eine spaltung der gesellschaft fest steht digitalisierung und künstliche intelligenz ki
haben ein riesiges potenzial aber natürlich werden wir als gesellschaft auch mit entsprechenden konsequenzen
leben müssen auch das war ein heiß diskutiertes thema unter den mehr als 70
expertinnen und experten hier wird befürchtet dass ein solcher fortschritt in diesen bereichen zu wenig menschen zugute kommen wird die sprache ist von einer
technisch globalen elite und lokal frustrierten auf der anderen seite eine spaltung der gesellschaft
wäre dann die folge einige derjenigen die diese warnung offen aussprechen kommen selbst aus amerikanischen
technologiekonzern unter anderem ihnen maske oder auch der apple mitbegründer steve wozniak
studien zeigen dass vor allem in den usa die angst vor technik getriebene
arbeitslosigkeit sehr groß ist macht bald eine maschine meinen job das deutsche ausbildungssystem
Könnte eine lösung sein menschen so zu qualifizieren dass sie sich auch in einer veränderten arbeitswelt
zurechtfinden diese drei themengebiete waren womit die wichtigsten und fest steht alle werden unsere zukunft maßgeblich
mitbestimmen wenn als erstes neues zum thema zukunft der menschheit und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
Endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
Täglich garantiert ihr könnt uns direkt über mich in der redaktion von krieg zum mitmachen und mit bestimmen was hierbei kriegs um so
passiert und zur begrüßung habe ich ein kleines geschenk für euch parat einfach hier draufklicken
und natürlich nicht das abo mit der genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
führt syrien zum dritten weltkrieg was wäre wenn ansonsten bis dann
blatter